we're talking about a segment of the
Beltway around Washington DC where it
should take you 23 minutes to go along
that 10 or 15 mile route it takes you
nearly an hour and a half the three
steps toward improving mobility is
certainly increase in capacity that's
one as a base of principle the second is
to really look at ways of allocating
that capital that that investment in a
way that's efficient and productive and
that's using market-oriented thinking
that includes at this point we'd have to
use cost-benefit analysis in that type
of thing but the third principle is by
using comprehensive pricing really
overlay a market-oriented framework on
top of physical infrastructure so in
terms of the future in terms of how
we're going to decide what roads are put
where in that it really can rely and
should rely on pricing this is not
without precedent historically trolley
lines were extended out to new areas to
facilitate urban development and those
were fully in many cases they were fully
paid for by the private sector by the
land developers so it's really a
question of updating a principle that
got lost in the 20th century and using
modern technology with all the
efficiencies that have come with that as
well as a good market oriented framework
to thinking about transportation that
allows us to update it and really
provide for efficient investments but
the bottom line is that if you're not
willing to pay for the investments in
infrastructure that infrastructure
probably should not be invested so all
three things have to come together in
order for us to make a meaningful impact
on mobility in the United States
you